[Applause]
Wonder Woman is out and I'll kind of
skip to the punchline it feels good
Hawaii @ec movie oh I gotta gotta get
you I gazed this feeling again it's it's
very unfamiliar for for quite a while
now so yes I have seen Wonder Woman and
I have enjoyed it quite a bit I have a
feeling that you've got to get into
spoilers before too long because some of
the things I want to talk about
specifically are spoilery and I'm not
going to do a separate video on that
because I don't have a big you know
overall message to go along with my
spoiler thoughts but I'll try and get
the spoiler free out of life it is good
it's very good
I personally has a date to call it great
because there are a number of things
holding back some of which I kind of
have to save a little bit for spoilers
but the things that bothered me do not
break the film they're aspects one of
which I'm actually kind of up to mind on
because it's one thing I don't like
about it one thing that I do a part of
it has to do with the origin story they
went with Wonder Woman has had a number
of different origins over the years the
one day when wood is one that I
personally don't favor but the film
handles that pretty well so that's more
my issue with the specific piece of
source material he chose to pull that
from so I'll set that aside as well the
performances are good gelded oak is
terrific in this party is a wonderful
presence and she will she really is
terrifically casting I wasn't completely
sold on her in BBS not that there was
anything wrong with what she did but I
just I felt like I didn't see enough of
the character's personality to actually
get a full sense of whether she worked
she does she's great
Chris Pine terrific as Steve Trevor
brings just enough levity yet also sells
himself as someone who is just buried in
this war that he wishes wasn't going on
and sells that very well though most of
the rest of the supporting cast does
very well to which some of them are
little OneNote but that happens
nothing's perfect at a candy didn't
great on me she was pretty well handled
um there are some companions too
Steve Trevor that I actually think work
better in terms of selling the
camaraderie of that team then say
Howling Commandos were done in Captain
America the First Avenger the action is
well done I can follow it the music is
great even though they still use that
Wonder Woman theme that appear to be via
which I still don't like but the moments
that they chose to play that theme in
this movie it did actually work for the
rest of the music I liked a lot I am
seriously considering picking up this
soundtrack it's interesting I was
talking to my friend Ryan as we were
coming out and he pointed out that the
overall tone of this thing is still
pretty dark it's pretty heavy because it
is you know being a world war one and
it's the story of Diana coming to
Maryland seeing basically has been
seeing something so bad that it's going
to make her kind of swear off the world
of men for a while which is you know
what we already knew coming in from BBS
oh it was going to have to be dark so
it's not a lighter movie but it does
have a specific key component that say
BBS absolutely did not have and that is
a beacon a sense of hope and something
to grab on to his being okay this is
dark and things are bad but here is our
thing to grab onto a question go okay
this can make us better and that is
appropriately Wonderwoman herself in
terms of the writing the way the
characters use the way gal gadot plays
her she really is very much in the same
way that Captain America the character
in the portrayal were what truly
elevated that first Captain America film
she does a similar thing here and I'm
not just making that comparison because
theyre both period war movies the
characters serve similar functions and
they fulfill those functions equally as
well in their respective movies are they
I'm going to start to get into spoilers
a little bit from here so if you don't
want any more than that move along I am
going to get into my criticisms right
now because I want to end on a positive
note and end on why these criticisms
that I have don't kill the movie because
usually I do my criticisms on the tail
end so stuff that's a little rough
Diana's naivete is something I'm of two
minds of there were moments particularly
in regards to her persistent belief that
if she can just find and kill Ares the
world will just end and it's so obvious
if right off the bat like that's not
gonna holla were self her insistence
that that's going to work it I didn't
like it and just sort of knowing that is
that absolute was not going out be how
it played out so her sincere insistence
on it and I understand why she's like
that I'm not saying it's unjustified I
just didn't like it that having been
said they pay it off well towards the
end when she does in fact realize no
this is not just Ares and that men are
causing this and they are doing this to
themselves and they are not what she
thought they were and that moment of
that scene between her and Steve Trevor
plays really really well so I didn't
like that function of her character but
it pays off well and some of the other
moments that where her 90k is played for
the work was what like when she asked
what's marriage and that little moment
plays well so that aspect of her
character did give some good moments but
also give some of the more painful
moments for me personally at any rate
the climax and the end date is a bit
reminds me a little bit too much of BBS
and in the sense of the other variant in
BBS the the doomsday fight and it's you
know that noise and fury and CGI and it
and I sort of lost the thread a little
bit I didn't completely check out
because thankfully it held an emotional
Center that I don't think BBS was able
to do and so that kind of a kind of
muscles through on that basis but the
climax at least in terms of the final
confrontation was not the emotional or
the action highlight
the film there are so good emotional
beats going on in the climax but they're
related to Steve as opposed to what she
has going on with the area area I'll
talk about briefly
David so let's actually place in pretty
well there's a lot there's an
interesting twist on and then there's
more nuance to the character than I was
expecting in terms of his not
necessarily wanting to cause war like
because war feeds his power which is a
more traditional sort of comic book
version of the Ares instead of two like
no none of the other gods understand man
is awful and through war we can get them
to destroy themselves because we got to
get rid of these things that was an
interesting take and I actually think
David goos brought a fair amount of
gravitas to his portrayal that there
were a couple of goofy moments he has
his flashbacks but they still had the
mustache on him then that that did
actually cause laughter in the screening
that I was asked speaking of visuals
that didn't quite work there's some bad
green-screen in this like really bad
like there's a shot early on of young
Diana oh the young the young and teenage
Diana's we get very good by the way but
there's a shot early on of young Diana
she like does this jump down and it's
you know it's on her the backgrounds
going behind oh it's really really bad I
think in some ways you can see where
because this had a lower budget then
something like BBS had it's not like a
low budget movie but you can kind of see
where the effects aren't quite up to the
same standard that we've seen from these
and while there are some interesting
shades that Ares some of the other
villains like Danny Huston who than
actors were normally really like he's
very OneNote which I get to a certain
extent they were really trying to sell
them as a red herring in terms of saying
oh he marries so I get why he's that way
but it is a little disappointing doctor
poison was an interesting visual I
actually kind of really liked some of
the unnerving uncanny valley this of
that cracked mask piece they had for her
but ultimately she's just kind of dishes
she glorified henchmen she plays well
enough and coming back to Diana's origin
a little bit while I'm not going to come
about how this is not my preferred
version of her origin I will say that
they Telegraph really early on and
really blatantly that the oh that her
origin that was told to her by her
mother obviously is not in the case that
I think I'm not sure they played that
entirely right but here's the thing
for everything that I just complained
about doesn't sink the movie doesn't
even come close because there was one
thing that this film does better than
certainly any other DC movie better than
a lot of the Marvel movies what it does
really well is rousing is triumph and
again embodied in Diana herself so when
she is going to steal that sword and
she's realizing her own power she's
climbing the wall that just huge grin
the best scene in the movie and my mind
by far is when she goes out onto that
battlefield as she goes out into
no-man's land and she faces the that
army and that scene and then going into
what happens in the village after that
is its it is rowdy as you pumped up and
it gives you the sense of hope and yes
and part of the reason it sells out so
well is that in contrast really well
with the fact that the movie does make a
point of showing how horrible this war
is and so while it is kind of a dark and
awful world in this case it feels much
more justified that the world is like
that then say with bbs were it just kind
of seemed like it was like that because
we wanted to make the film dark here it
is dark and depressing and an awful
place but it feeds into the message it
feeds into why Diana feels the need to
try and stop all this and it elevates
the moment when she gets to be that
beacon of hope and again that beacon of
hope is very much what BBS was lacking
so for me this thing does those
triumphant rousing moments so well it
plasters over a lot of since pretty much
all of them again I because those issues
still exist I do hesitate to call the
movie great but it is
very good I am very happy that I saw it
and it is by a mile
better than anything else that the DC EU
has put out so those are my thoughts on
Wonder Woman what are yours whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
or the punch like a girl podcast
available on separate feeds on iTunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]